]Marvel Studios' “Eternals” is a big movie, with
big heroes, an epic storyline and cinematography
screaming to be seen in IMAX. As such, it’s easy
to lose track of the film’s smaller characters.
Here are some "Eternals" characters
who mean more than you realize.
"Let's go!"
Remember when Scarlett Johansson appeared in
“Iron Man 2”? It was noteworthy, for sure,
because Johansson was already a big star
with films like “Lost in Translation”
and would-be blockbusters like “The Island”
under her belt. But her first appearance as
Natasha Romanoff felt like the character was
intended to be a scene-stealing sidekick,
not someone who’d go on to become a top MCU
character and get her own spin-off movie.
There’s reason to believe that Kit Harington’s
Dane Whitman could be set for a similar ascension
in this newest MCU phase. In “Eternals,”
it’s almost laughable how non-heroic he is,
existing for two apparent reasons: to
ask the questions fans want answered,
and to be a supportive boyfriend.
“Why didn’t you guys help fight Thanos? Or any
war, or all the other terrible
things throughout history?”
As Sersi reveals to Dane that she is a god-like
being, has been on Earth for 7000 years,
and has an ex-boyfriend who could
disintegrate him with the blink of an eye,
Dane just makes goo goo eyes and
takes her for long, romantic walks.
"How long were you together?"
"5000 years."
"I guess you can call that 'long-term.'"
Which feels a little beneath the “Game of
Thrones” actor who just finished playing Jon Snow,
Lord Commander of the Night’s Watch, King
in the North, Lord of the Seven Kingdoms
and Protector of the Realm. Now Kit
Harington is just ... a boyfriend?
Perhaps this apparent insignificance
is because, in scenes we never witness,
he is indeed on his own hero’s journey throughout
the film. Near the end of the film, Dane tells
Sersi his family history is "complicated”
and, as any Marvel fan with a smartphone
and a search engine can tell you, “Dane Whitman”
will one day become a hero called "Black Knight."
Of course, the most obvious reveal that
Kit Harington will soon be wielding the
legendary Ebony Blade sword and riding on
horseback is the second post-credits scene.
We see Dane addressing a family legacy that
stretches back to the days of King Arthur.
Examining the Ebony Blade, he delivers
the ominous phrase “Death is my reward,”
before an off-camera voice interrupts him
with “Are you sure you’re ready for that?”
Rumor has it that Dane’s story will be continued
in 2022’s “Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness.” In the comics, the Black Knight not
only becomes an Avenger, but is known for his
ability to navigate different time periods and
alternate realities. Taking all this into account,
you can see how Harington’s character could become
instrumental over the next several Marvel films.
On the surface, Kingo's valet-slash-filmographer
feels like a walking punchline. Every time Kingo
does something heroic, Karun is there to
assure the Eternal that he got the shot;
every time someone smashes his camera, Karun
hilariously seems to whip out another one.
"Kingo the movie star!"
"I've directed some things too."
But look closer, and you’ll see the one human that
the Eternals have come to trust
more than they ever have before,
over thousands of years. Granted, it’s not like
they have much choice — Kingo insists that his
valet come along for the reunion — but over time,
they begin warming to the man behind the camera.
When the smoke clears, Karun possesses not
only the friendship and trust of the Eternals,
but an incredibly valuable
assemblage of raw footage.
Imagine being in possession of film footage
that would immediately render all theology,
religion and world history irrelevant.
What will Karun do with this footage?
What is he willing to do with it? And would
he do anything without Kingo’s approval?
By the end of the film, the world likely
knows that some major events have occurred,
but it’s debatable whether the Eternals have
“revealed” themselves. It seems that as their
story moves along in the MCU, their existence
will become common knowledge; don’t be surprised
if all that seemingly-comic-relief footage shot
by Karun is what drags them into the spotlight.
While “Eternals” breaks multiple boundaries
within the Marvel Cinematic Universe,
it treats most of these exactly the
way they should be treated: as normal,
everyday life. One of these is a relationship
between Phastos and his husband Ben, who the
other Eternals learn have been building a life
together in Chicago with their adorable son Jack.
"Dad! That's Superman! With the cape! And you
were shooting laser beams out of your eyes!"
"I don't wear a cape."
This is the first time a same sex couple
has been featured in a Marvel Studios film.
Their kiss, as Phastos is headed off to save
the world, is not only a powerful moment,
but a significant one for the LGBTQ community.
Considering how many millions of people all over
the globe watch every Marvel film, it also means
a great deal personally to actor Haaz Sleiman,
who came out as gay in 2017. The actor
explained to Variety at the film’s premiere,
“Beyond a dream come true, it’s life-saving. I
wish I had that [representation] when I was a
kid [...] My god. I wish! Can you imagine how
many lives this is going to be saving — kids,
young queer folk who are being bullied [...] And
now they get to see this — it’s above and beyond.”
According to writer/director Chloe Zhao,
Marvel had already laid out a blueprint for
the family of Phastos when she came on board.
Finding true love after thousands of years
returns a faith in humanity to Phastos,
and leads to his personal decision to not only
fight for humans, but eventually return to them.
So on one level, Ben might feel just like
another “supportive spouse” character in the MCU,
no different than Hawkeye’s
wife Laura. On another level,
that might make him one of the most important
characters we’ve ever seen in the MCU.
Sprite is among the very first Eternals,
debuting in 1976’s “Eternals” issue 9.
But in the comics, she is typically a he,
who inspired both Shakespeare (who created
the character Puck in his image) and J.M.
Barrie (who did the same with Peter Pan).
Because “Eternals” features 10 main heroes,
there isn’t a lot of time for deep dives into
these characters. As such, Sprite feels like
one of the Eternals that gets short shrift.
In the comics, Sprite is much more fully-realized,
and employs illusions much more frequently.
Every bit as mischievous as Loki, Sprite
also possesses matter-manipulating
abilities similar to Sersi, and is
strong enough to lift several tons.
In “Eternals,” Sprite is compared to the
Peter Pan story — not as its inspiration,
but because the way she secretly yearns
to be with Ikaris is reminiscent of how
Tinkerbell can never be with
the boy who wouldn’t grow up.
Ultimately, however, the MCU Sprite feels
more like Pinocchio, who yearned to be real.
In “Eternals Volume 5” issue 1, released just
a few months before the movie was released,
it was revealed that the Eternals
switch gender every few thousand years.
This is never mentioned in the movie, but the
fan favorite character is depicted as being
female when she first appears on Earth, as well
as thousands of years later in the modern age.
Another Eternal who gets the Reader’s
Digest-treatment in the feature film is Gilgamesh.
Another comic character whose history with
the title stretches back to the mid-‘70s,
that history has intermingled
with Hercules, Achilles,
Buffalo Bill and King David — and for a
time, he even fought for the Roman Empire.
Perhaps it is appropriate, in a way, that he
seems to receive the least screen time of any
of the Eternals. In the pages of Marvel
Comics, he was punished for many years
after learning about the true nature
of his heritage. Confined to Olympia,
he was branded “The Forgotten One,” and
was subsequently ostracized for centuries.
In the movie, Gilgamesh is a chef that
enjoys preparing bountiful feasts,
and has also taken on the personal
task of becoming a caretaker for Thena.
He also wields a big powerful punch, which
feels a bit redundant after Marvel audiences
have already seen several other characters
who can do essentially the same thing.
In the film, each Eternal is depicted
as having their own unique power;
in the comics, Gilgamesh, who joined the Avengers
for a brief period, also has superhuman speed,
can shoot beams of cosmic energy, and can use his
telekinetic power to take flight. Which is all
very impressive, but perhaps not nearly as much as
that meal he makes for the Eternals in Australia.
"This is really good, Gil."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "Eternals"
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.